A couple things that that took me a long
time to figure out.
Um
there's this very there's these two
opposing forces of like make good [__]
and then make lots of [__]
That you have people on both sides. I
tend to be on the make lots of [__]
category. Um but these are two apparent
extremes that sit where the magic is in
the middle.
And so we've referred internally as this
middle spot as qualium. Which is how do
we create quality volume. And if you
guys haven't read this book, it recently
I think it recently came out. It's
called uh the algorithm. It's from
Tesla's former president who kind of
reimagined some of their stuff. And
basically it's it's it's Elon's approach
to manufacturing anything, right? And so
if you think about what content creation
is, it's a manufacturing process. It's
digital manufacturing, but you're taking
a raw input of just like recording some
video and then there's an output which
is going to be a post on social media or
multiple posts on social media. They're
going to get views, likes, shares,
leads, etc., right?
And so the five steps of algorithm and
I'll walk you through them. Um I I made
this mandatory for all the people who
report to me because this is this is the
process that I I've I first heard about
this 2 years ago
uh from some interview that Elon did and
I was like, "Man, this is really good."
Uh and they finally came out with a book
on it. So, let me just walk you through
it and then we'll get into content
questions, all right? So, the first step
is question the requirements and I'll
give you an example. So, I say, "Okay,
why does it take?" And the great the
first great way to know that something
is taking way too long is to say, "How
much actual time are you working on the
thing?" So, whether this is client work
uh or this is like you're on you know,
you're doing home services and you're
working on a project. Whatever it is,
like there's a certain amount of work
that um that has to be done, right? Now,
let's say the total time on task or
total total time that the work is being
done is say 10 hours, right? But all of
a sudden you're like, "But then why is
it taking us a week to get this
delivered, right? It should in a perfect
world go from they sign and then 10
hours later they get." Right? So
everything that's outside of 10 hours is
waste from a business perspective
because it's basically uncaptured
potential value. All right. And so the
idea when we asked the first step is
when we question the requirements is
like why must these things happen in
this order? Why are we doing all these
requirements? Why must it take this long
etc. right? And so with the questioning
of the requirements, one of the things
that came up I was like okay. They're
like well one of the things that we do
in this these 10 hours for example is
that we color grade. Right? And I was
like okay. Uh do we think color grading
even [__] matters? And if we look at
some of the best videos that I have they
weren't color graded and there's some
absolute bombs that are color graded.
And I'm like okay. So how much time is
this?
And is it a requirement? Who decided
that we must color grade everything?
What what what god on the throne of of
YouTube and Instagram said that color
grading was super important? The answer
is there wasn't really one. Right? So we
remove color grading
from our from our process step. And it's
like what else can we cut? Right? And so
the idea is once you figure out all the
requirements that exist, we have to
question the requirements and I'll give
you the three step questions that I
asked. This is not Elon's. Which is what
does that mean?
How do you know that?
So what?
Right? So we have to color grade. Okay.
What does that mean? It means we have to
do all this [__] to the video. Okay. Now
that you say that, so what? Do we have
any evidence? Right? That that this is
going to do anything to the video? No,
we have no evidence. All right. So why
should I care?
There isn't. And so when I question the
requirements I answer ask those two
questions. What does that mean?
How do you know that? And so what?
Right? Once we have that it's like boom.
That's the first thing. When you have
the answers to all those questions and
requirements and you say okay. Well
let's just delete a [__] load of stuff.
And one of Elon's rules of thumb is we
should delete so much that we have to
add stuff back. Which is a great litmus
test because everyone's always afraid of
deletion because everyone's afraid of
like messing something up. But you can
always add stuff back. It's very
unlikely that in a process especially
when you're building something that Um,
an irreversible door. You know what I
mean? It's not like you're going to blow
up a machine you have or you're going to
like, you know, one of your editors
going to disappear from the planet. No,
it's like the step the step in the
process that we can we can add back if
we want to. Let's just see what happens.
And so when I first started doing this,
you might have seen this video that I
posted on YouTube which was um
it was like if you're broke, watch this
or something like that. Um, which I
guess that's every [__] video on
YouTube, but whatever.
I won't rant on that. Whatever, I'll let
that go. But it was me on a plane and I
did it with an iPhone. And I did it that
way because I was so angry, let me
honest, I was I was a little peeved at
the team because they were like, "We
have to do all these things." And
thankfully all almost all that team is
is not with us anymore.
>> [laughter]
>> So, and so when we did the video, right,
and we posted it, it became a mando one
out of 10 video because the thing that
mattered is the stuff in the [__]
video, right? And so everyone wants to
to major in the minors, right? Which is
part of the reason that I'm doing these
raw videos like this cuz like it was
never about the [__] production,
right? And some of you guys are worried
about your makeup and for the girls,
right? Or the lighting or to be fair,
this is an epic background, so this is
probably a little off. But like most of
the time my background looks absolute
dog [__] and is either, you know, blurry
in my death star of a production center,
which I also hate, but um, or it's in my
office, which looks horrible, right? And
so my point is this is that like the
thing that matters is the stuff inside.
It's the stuff inside of the content.
The content is the container, right? The
stuff inside is what matters. And so if
you don't have the stuff, like focus on
the stuff. That's where the quality
comes from. The volume is like how much
stuff I'm going to put out. All right.
So number one, what what question
requirements? Here's our big list of
[__] Number two, we delete the stuff
that doesn't matter. We should delete so
much that we have to add stuff back
later. Three is simplify. Another way of
saying that is optimize. What do we get
the most for the least? So even though
something um, might give us a return,
let's say color grading gives us a
return, I'll just make it up. Um, and
let's say we can prove that, which we
can't. But let's say we can prove it.
Okay. Um, if we can prove it, is it
worth it? Right? Which is a separate
question. Is it worth it? So, we can get
um
let's say let's say the total thing
takes 10 hours. Okay. Let's say four of
those hours are color grading. All
right. Is it 40% of the quality of the
output?
No.
Is it 5%? Maybe.
Is it worth 40% of the costs? My
argument, no. I would rather because we
have to put the opportunity cost. If I
had if my team had nothing else to edit,
then it would make sense to take the
extra time. But they have so much other
stuff to edit and it would make more
sense for us to do two videos or one and
a half videos at 95% than one video at
100. All right. So, hear me out on that.
After simplifying or optimizing most for
the least, then you go to step four,
which is accelerate. How do you pull up
timelines? I'll give you my my version
of doing this when I'm in a meeting. So,
anybody who's worked with me knows that
I like to finish meetings with who,
what, when. So, it's my very simple
management algorithm. That's about it.
Everything else you can learn from
Layla, but these three, this is what I
do.
And so, at the end of our meeting, I'm
like, who, what, when, right? Who is
going to do what by when? Very, very
simple, right? And here's where if you
want to go to the 201 level, whenever
someone tells you the by when, you
actually ask the question I started
with, which is
okay, uh today's Monday and you want to
do this by next meeting next Monday, how
much actual time is this going to take?
Time on task. And so, people will be
like, uh I think it'll take me 4 hours.
It's like, okay.
What are you doing in the next 4 hours
that is more important than this?
A lot of times the answer is nothing. In
which case, great. Do it do it by end of
day.
And let me know. And so, if you ever
want to speed up the movement of a team,
increase communication cycles. So, that
means instead of going end of week, go
end of day. It's 7x is the speed of a
team. You will be amazed at how much
more you get done. So, who, what, when?
So, who's going to do what by when? And
then when they tell you when, you ask
why can't you do it earlier? Now, to be
clear, if someone says I got this other
[__] that's going on that you told me to
do, right? You're like, "Oh yeah, I did
tell you to do that." Then it's like,
"Great, we'll do that after that,
right?" And then that way that constant
accountability
just drives the whole thing forward. And
so, I promise you if you want a project
to go faster, ask for updates every day,
twice a day, five times a day,
every hour. I'm telling you, like, I've
done this with vendors, too. So, if I'm
like, "Hey,
uh hey, I need this thing." And they're
like, "Okay, cool, we'll get it to you
tomorrow." I'll just call them in an
hour and be like, "Hey, what's our
progress update on that?" And they're
like, "I I said I'll get it to you." I'm
like, "This is very important to me.
Like, can we can we please get this done
sooner?" And then you call them again in
an hour. They're like, "Dude, I'll
[__] get it done." It's like,
"Right." So, I will force the
accountability on a vendor if I need to
pull [__] forward. And so, that's fourth
step is how do we pull up cycles? How do
we how do we take what the expected
timeline is and then reduce it?
And then, and this is the big this is
the big one which AI has destroyed for
everyone.
Step five is automate. Which is okay,
how do we get the machines to do it?
Now, here's the here's the uh here's the
magic behind this.
Because the access to AI has become so
prevalent and so easy for everyone,
everyone thinks in the first step the
last step first. They try and automate
[__] that should not be done to begin
with.
With like cuz the only thing that is
more efficient than automation is
elimination. It's choosing not to do
something is more efficient than
automating it because it wasn't worth to
do it to begin with. And so, the easiest
litmus test for many of you people uh
you people for many of you is
though I am using AI,
are we getting more views? Though I am
using AI, are we getting more leads?
Though I am using AI, am I making more
money?
And so, that's the very easy litmus test
to tell you whether or not this is
actually makes sense.
And so, I will promise you that Claude
or, you know, Anthropic or, you know,
OpenAI, etc.
Claude and Anthropic are the same
company, but, you know, company's doing
the billing, right?
Um Gemini, whatever. If they're billing
you, they're billing you whether what
you built was useful or not. And so if
you're noticing your tokens cost going
up month over month over month, but your
money's not going up month over month
over month, maybe you should consider
that you're actually just blowing money
on [__] that doesn't matter.
And so you maybe should start start with
that process of the algorithm. All
right? Question the requirements,
delete all stupid requirements, simplify
aka optimize get the most for the least,
speed up cycle cuz how do we do it
faster? And then finally then and only
then
do we bring up automation.
Because then you're you're automating
something that has already been
maximized for effectiveness and now
you're just getting the last bit of
effectiveness out of it, which is
getting the robots to do it for you. All
right. Um
with that being said, uh we've we've
worked on our content a lot. This is the
year
of the trust economy. Um I think I
called this at the end of last year and
I feel like I'm more right. I think it
ages like a fine wine. Um we're in we're
in the we're in the show-me times, not
the tell-me times.
All right? And so that means that we
need to you need to demonstrate
expertise in as many varied conditions
as possible with as many diverse avatars
or rather the avatars that represent
most broadly
uh the types of customers that you serve
solving the specific problems that they
have in the way that you want to solve
them that gets them the outcome they're
looking for.
All right? That is content from an
education perspective that drives
commerce. That is content that drives
commerce. That is views that turn into
cash. Right? If you're just getting
you're like doing memes or doing
entertainment, there's nothing wrong
with that. It's just that you're just a
media business and eventually going to
sell eyeballs to an advertiser, right?
But if you want to sell from your own
[__] right? Sell your own [__] You
want to sell community own school. You
want to sell you want to sell fencing
services. You want to sell you want to
sell home design. You want to sell
solar. Whatever the hell you're selling,
education is the door, right? That is
how you gain influence. That is how you
gain authority. That you give people
instructions that they can follow and
good [__] happens for them. Now, in
order for them to follow your
instructions, there's a couple things
that have to have to happen.
Number one, the instructions have to be
easy to follow, right? Which means you
got to talk in the in words that other
people understand.
All right? Number two,
they have to believe you that they
should that they are worth following.
So, if we decrease the comprehension, we
decrease the cost of at least
understanding what to do. Right? Then we
have to increase conviction that they're
going to get the payoff, which makes the
risk or the gamble of taking those
actions worth it.
Right? And so, this is why the proof in
this trust economy world is not in the
pudding, but it is the [__] pudding.
Right? The reason that proof is what
matters more than anything is because
tell me how you're going to grow my
e-commerce store except you've never run
an e-commerce store.
Right? Tell me how you're going to teach
me how to sell except you've never sold
anything. Tell me how you're going to
help me make content, but you don't have
a personal brand.
Right? Like it's just the big obvious
[__] And I get these questions all the
time like, "How do I build a personal
brand?" It's like, "Just do shit." You
will You will get a bigger personal
brand by doing [__] in reality for 5
years and then starting your personal
brand. Now, to be clear, I think if you
want to document along the way, as long
as you state the facts and tell the
truth, you're good you're good in my
book. Right? But what happens is people
are like, "How do I How do I counter
imposter syndrome?" I'm like, "Bro,
imposter syndrome is you feeling ashamed
for lying." Oops, there we go. Is you
feeling ashamed for lying because you
are misrepresenting the truth. Sorry,
I'm trying to adjust this thing so it's
not [__] up. Here we go.
Um is you misrepresenting the truth,
Jesus. This is why we can't have nice
things. Hold on.
Yeah? Yeah? Ah, [__] good enough.
See if that works. All right. Um
And so, I'll give you an example of this
whole imposter syndrome thing that you
should probably just abolish from your
your mental whatever.
Here it is. So, I had a guy who came up
to me uh at at one of our workshops in
Vegas and he was like, "Hey, man. Um how
do you deal with imposter syndrome?" I
was like, "All right, what do you What
do you sell, man?" He said, "I help
agency owners
uh get booked appointments." And I was
like, "Okay. uh, how do you do it?" And
he's like, "We run outbound teams." I
was like, "Okay, that makes sense. I get
it." I was like, "So, what are you
dealing with imposter syndrome for?" And
he's like, "Well,
you know, I had an agency, but the
agency didn't really work that that
well. Uh, I didn't really make any money
with it uh, because I knew how to get
customers, but I I couldn't really keep
them."
I was like, "Okay."
Still trying to figure out where the
imposter syndrome coming from.
And he was like, "Well,"
I was like, "Are you pretending like
you're good at running an agency?" And
he was like,
"Kind of." And I was like, "Yeah, bro.
That imposter syndrome is lying.
So, yeah, you should feel bad about
lying.
Okay? I was like, "But if you told the
truth, it probably would be even more
effective. If you just said, 'Hey, I had
an agency. I sucked at running an
agency. I was really good at selling
agency clients. And so then I said,
well, why don't I just do that for
agency owners who are actually good at
delivering for clients?' And then this
business was born. Everyone would be
like, 'Oh, that actually makes a lot of
sense.' And so what you forget is that
the truth is the most compelling thing
out there from a marketing perspective.
The reason that state the facts and tell
the truth is the number one thing that
we say
at acquisition.com in marketing is
because it sells the most. The truth
sells the most. I will say this again.
The truth sells the most. The truth
converts.
All right? Above everything else. But,
it has to be the whole [__] truth.
All right? It has to be the whole truth.
And so he can't say
uh, just half of the story. You have to
say all the [__] where you look bad,
too. And then people will believe the
[__] where you look good.
That's the That's the whole game.
Right? I got asked a bunch of times
throughout my career. They're like, "So,
should I think I was on Diary of a CEO."
He's like, "Alex, should people talk to
you about happiness?" I'm like, "No.
That's not I don't have authority there.
All right? I'm the like, "Hey, you're
trying to figure out how to scale your
business?" That's me. You're like,
"Trying to how to figure out how to sell
shit?" That's me. I can help you there.
I got a lot of proof there. Real quick,
I'm going to show you the exact 10-stage
roadmap from zero to 100 million plus
that less than 1% of companies finish
I've now done multiple times. And so I
can say with a lot of confidence that
these are the stages as head count
increases that you need to get through.
And I broke each of these down by eight
different functions of the business,
what the constraint feels like, like
what are the symptoms of it when you're
going through it, and then what steps we
actually took to graduate. And we've
done this across software, physical
products, uh service businesses, brick
and mortar, all of this, and it works.
And it's my gift to you. It's absolutely
free. And so the link's in the
description, but you just go
acquisition.com/roadmap.
Just enter your info and it'll spit it
right back to you, all free.